- I went on America's Got
Talent and got kicked off
the show.
They told me I'd never
make it as a performer.
And then I started doing
YouTube and then everything
took off.
And when your passion is
what you do for a living,
it's very hard to not become a workaholic.
If you're not happy with
the person you are today,
I 100% believe that you can change.
- She's an American
violinist, singer, songwriter,
composer, and performing artist.
Her music video, Crystalize,
was the eighth most watched
video in 2012.
As of July 2016 her YouTube
channel has over eight
million subscribers and
over a billion views.
She's Lindsay Sterling and
here's my take on her top
10 rules to success.
Rule number two is my personal
favorite and make sure
to stick around all the way
to the end for some special
bonus clips.
And, as always, as Lindsay's
talking if she says something
that really resonates with
you, please leave it in the
comments below, put quotes
around it so other people
can be inspired as well.
Enjoy.
(upbeat music)
- I think, honestly, being
true to yourself is the
absolute key to being successful
in this kind of a model.
Because you can't fake
authenticity, you can't fake
loving something.
And honestly, to any
artistic form or medium,
you have to work so hard to
get your stuff heard or seen.
And so if you don't absolutely
love it you will burn
yourself out and the only
way I'm able to do what I do
is I'm almost a workaholic
because I love what I'm doing.
And it's okay.
Because I'm enjoying it and
because I love the people
that I work with, it doubles
as work and recreation
and if I didn't love it
it would be impossible.
I went on America's Got
Talent and got kicked off
the show, they told me I'd
never make it as a performer.
And then I started doing
YouTube and then everything
took off.
And so to be able, to be
invited back to one of the
biggest shows in America
and a show that I got kicked
off of, to be invited back, it
was a really cool experience
just because a lot of
people don't get the chance
to redo a moment of their life
that was very devastating.
And to be able to go back
on that stage and do it
the way I wanted to do it
and be able to give the
performance I wanted,
it was really awesome.
- There were also critics on the show,
the judges were not always nice with you.
Wasn't it like judgment
day where you felt like,
"Ha ha, I'm back and
this time I'm a star."
- You know, kind of, it was.
I hope that my fans and
other people saw it that way,
in the way of, you can't
let anyone else tell you
who you are and how good you because,
everyone has their own opinions,
but I hope that they see,
"Wow the same way Lindsay
didn't listen to them
"and she went back and was
able to prove them wrong,
"I can do that.
"If someone at school is
mean to me, it doesn't mean
"that I'm a bad person,
it doesn't mean I'm a dork
"or a loser, I can become
whoever I want to be."
And I hope that people see
that because that moment
proved that to me and it's true.
I wish, so when I first
started I wish I had realized
that people were the most
important thing to me.
Because there was a time,
you know, I'm such a hard
worker and when your passion
is what you do for a living,
it's very hard to not become a workaholic.
And there was a time where
I just almost lost sight of
everything that was most
important to me because I was
working so hard and I was
pushing so hard for these
dreams and these goals and
everything I wanted in life,
and my life started to look
very gray and colorless
and I realized I had lost a
lot of depth because I wasn't
making time for those
most important things,
which are my family.
You know, the people in my
life or someone that maybe
needed me at a time, but I
was too bust to even notice.
And those are the things that you can't,
you can't fulfill your full passion,
whether it's through
music or art or dance,
if you've lost sight of
the things that make you
a real person.
And I had to refind myself, almost, like,
"Wow, what is it that makes me me?"
And once I re-found that
it's like everything else
came together again.
I was able to write again,
I was able to create,
but without those things,
then you lose sight of
everything.
I think like you said,
every single artist goes
through that.
And I think a lot of times
you think that the great
writers are the people, they
just write hit after hit
after hit, and they do
but it's also because they
get through all the terrible songs first.
And, I mean, I think
that's kind of every single
artist story.
And, I mean, I love to
tell, when people ask,
"What's your best advice
for an upcoming musician,
"or anybody?" I think it's
that you have to be able
to rise form the failures
is what makes a successful
person.
'Cause everybody's going to have mishaps,
they're going to fall down,
and it's the people that
continuously pick themselves
up that are the ones
that are going to find
their voice, make it,
whatever you want to call it.
- I love how for this
record you had fans actually
do little videos that
talked about what they were
brave enough to do in life.
So for you, what was the
moment you realized you were
brave enough to do this full time,
just go right after your passion?
- Oh, I think it's once
I discovered YouTube.
I mean, I had already been
going for it with full force
but I was kind of wondering
if I had what it took
to make it and I was really
discouraged at times 'cause
everywhere I went I just kept being told,
"No, you're not good enough."
And that can be really
discouraging and so even though
I was going for it, I was
kind of in the back of my
mind just really scared.
Like, "Am I going to
make it, I don't know."
And then when I finally
discovered YouTube and I put up
my first video, I just felt
so empowered and so excited
because I was like, "Whoa,
finally something's working."
And that's when I was like,
"I'm going to, I don't know how
"this is going to work out,
but I'm going to chase this
"with everything I've got."
And that's when I was like, boom!
- And what about the
appreciation of hip hop and EDM,
which both have played a role
in what you do musically?
When did you first encounter
those and how did you
come to love them?
- I really fell in love
with EDM when I first heard,
I always liked techno music,
I felt like it was kind of,
for lack of a better term,
it was great white girl
dance music.
I've always loved to dance and I was like,
"Oh these beats, I can dance to this."
It's not quite as, doesn't
need as much groove as
hip hop did.
So that's why I always
like EDM and then I really
fell in love with it when
I discovered Skrillex,
especially Bangarang.
That song, I was like, "Oh
my gosh, I have to figure out
"how I can pair the violin
with this weird dubstep stuff."
'Cause it was so fun and
it made me want to move.
And that was the beginning.
You know, it never becomes,
I don't think it'll ever
be like, "Oh, I don't care,
I don't care anymore."
Because I do care, it's
my art, it's my love,
it's my passion.
And certain comments you're able to like,
"Oh whatever," but there's
some comments that get you
in the place that you're
a little bit vulnerable.
- [Interviewer] That trigger you.
- That trigger you, they
get you, you're like,
"Don't talk about that,
that's actually something
"that I care about and I'm sensitive to."
And I think it's so
important to realize that,
especially in YouTube
there is so much good,
but for some reason it's
easier to focus on the
negative because it just,
it gets you so much more.
- You'll get thousands
of positive comments and
then 10 negative.
- One negative, you're like, "Oh dang it."
So it's so true that you
only really do have one
stage in your mind that
you can really focus on
at one time, and so the good, the bad,
they're going to come and what
are you going to focus on?
Am I going to sit and stew and respond,
especially responding, if
you respond to the negative,
that is a lot of times
the one that you want to
respond to.
But it's like, "Or am I
going to feed the good."
Am I going to feed these
people who keep coming back
and telling me really nice things,
that's where I should put my
energy, that's where I should
put my thoughts and focus
and it does take a lot of,
you know, concentration to do that.
- [Interviewer] Yeah, awareness too.
- Awareness, that's the
word I'm looking for.
But I think that's the key
is just there's good and bad
all around us, everywhere
and trying really hard to
focus on the good and let that feed you.
You know, every tour I
like to try to step it up.
I want my fans that have,
a lot of my fans come to
multiple shows and so I always
want them to be surprised
when they come back.
I don't want it to feel like
the last Lindsay Sterling
show.
And, you know, "Been there, done that."
So I always try to do
something that I've never done
before and this tour is a lot of fun.
There's some new tricks I
have up my sleeve that I,
you know, I worked really
hard to learn and to master
these new skills, but anyways,
super excited about it.
I think the courage to be
really open about some of
the things I've been through
in the past all comes
from experiencing those
things and when I was going
through, say, when I was
going through some of these
things I felt so alone and a
lot of girls, or people, do.
You feel like nobody can
understand you because a lot of
these problems deal
with isolating yourself
and feeling alone.
And one of the things that
really helped me have the
courage to change was I
realized that I'm not alone.
There's actually people who
understand me and there's
people who have actually overcome this.
And that gave me hope and
so that's why I really
strive to give a positive
message of hope about, like,
if you're not happy with
the person you are today,
I 100% believe that you can change.
So that's what I like to
hopefully share with young girls
and I would say that's what
gave me the courage to share.
I've always played the
violin ever since I was six
years old I begged for lessons
and I've always played.
And it was actually when I
was in college that I kind of
just realized one day that
I didn't love it anymore
and I used to love it.
And I specifically didn't
study music in school because
I didn't ever want to
have the love of my music
beat out of me.
So it kind of broke my
heart when I was like,
"I don't even enjoy this anymore."
And os I started thinking,
"What can I do to invigorate
"my passion?"
I started playing with bands,
I started anywhere I could
go to kind of try out new
styles of music and I've
always loved electronic music
and it just hit me one day,
"I need to play and write
the kind of music that I
"am loving right now."
And so I did and it just
brought it back to life for me,
it made it so creative
and I became a creator,
not just a musician
and that's I think what
invigorated my passion.
- Thank you guys so much for watching,
I made this video because
John Thoren asked me to.
So if there's a famous
entrepreneur that you want
me to profile next, leave
it down in the comments
below and I'll see what I can do.
I also love to know what
did Lindsay say that
had the biggest impact on
you, which rule did you
enjoy the most?
What are you going from
her message to immediately
apply to your life of business?
Please leave it in the
comments and I'm going to join
in the discussion.
Finally, I want to take a
quick shout at Steph Reveron.
Steph, thank you so much for
picking up a copy of my book,
Your One Word, and sending
in that picture of you
at the cafe reading it, I
hope you're enjoying it and
getting a lot of value from it.
So thank you guys again for
watching, I believe in you,
I hope you continue to
believe in yourself and
whatever your one word is.
Much love, I'll see you soon.
- It's the same way kids
look up to Taylor Swift
and they want to get a little
guitar and be Taylor Swift.
My parents used to take me
to orchestra concerts and so
that was my version of a rockstar.
I was like, "Oh my gosh,
I have to get one of those
"wooden things."
But yeah, I played classical
violin all growing up
and I started to just, I
had gotten burnt out and I
wanted to love it again and
so I started experimenting
with all different sorts of
music and I found out that
I absolutely loved EDM and
electronic dance and dubstep
music and nobody, no
record labels thought I was
worthwhile or that my
project was marketable and so
I started doing it myself
on YouTube and that's when
it just kind of, "Whoa, I
guess it is marketable,"
is what I kind of discovered.
I guess I surround my crew, my tour crew,
I surround myself with
really great people.
I have the best tour
crew and so they kind of,
I mean honestly, just say
one day I wanted to be crazy
and went out and got drunk,
they would all just be like,
"Whoa."
They would be so turned
off they'd just be like,
"What are you doing?"
They'd probably take the beer
out of my hand and be like,
"Come here, Lindsay,
what's wrong with you?"
Because they know me
so well and they just,
they're there to protect
me and help me, as well.
I wasn't like I have always
been a very optimistic upbeat
person.
When I first came to college,
it was a time that I was
trying to figure out, "Who
am I? What makes me special?"
And I started to find most
of my value in the fact
that I was thin.
For several years I had no
idea I had become anorexic.
And be places with people I cared about,
but what I was thinking
about was the extra grease
on the pizza or the
calories that I knew were in
that shake.
And I just was talking to
my mom one day and I broke
down crying because I
realized for the first time
that I had a problem and
that this isn't normal.
People don't think like this.
I finally realized I wasn't happy.
Any time there's a change to
be made, you have to realize
that there's somewhere
else you want to be.
And I wanted, basically, to be happy.
That was far more important
than being the skinniest
girl in a room.
Once I realized that there
was a problem that's when
I could change.
I knew that I could be happy again.